fake environments when you live in a
world that you can't afford because
you're keeping up with the Joneses scary
[ __ ] poison
a lot of people running the big credit
cards here to look right in their
environment look what I did
I've been my life all for my peers I'm
going in not sitting in designing my
story you're feeling it Dan yeah
imminent yeah you know that Simon day
M&A yeah you know that Simon day hello
hi how are you such a pleasure
how are you nice to meet you yeah hi
jasmine my sister Liz Raisa Duloc so far
so good we just got heard a couple hours
ago unlike any other CEO of any
organization that has 500 plus employees
in marketing client services in social
media
none of them are practitioners their
executives at a scale greater than
almost every other human on earth thus
allowing me to have unbelievable amount
of information an IP into what's
actually happening and the other thing
that I think I and that's the ego part
and then the humility part what I
understand is just cuz something works
for me it may not work for GE or sa P or
Pepsi and so I've been able to
synthesize the ability to understand
what works for an individual who's a 42
year old male in New York has this kind
of style I'm able to synthesize what
would happen if that was a 22 year old
female in Malaysia whether that was a
fortune 500 SAS company whether that's a
bottled water that interpretation of big
data is a talent of mine no problem
alright thank you so much thank you so
thank you so much guys thank you my
friend thank you thanks guys very nice
thing to do
bye thank you good luck of you to man
thank you such a pleasure
sit sit sit but it's not Malaysia tea
but it's meat from Malaysia it's a royal
salon oh thank you do open it this time
okay
[Applause]
something different but it's a royal
anguish meet from the trim ratio is
famous for this kid yes and thank you
but pastor I love it don't think you
have this collection I do not in the
pull of a royal slang I do not I'm gonna
have to get this on the shell Instagram
and MV yes I'm interested I am this is
amazing I love it I love it this is
fantastic thank you so much it's so nice
it's super cool yes I think blockchain
is like running a marathon the longest
marathon of your life I think the best
way to transfer a marathon is to get on
a treadmill every day to run a couple of
five K's I think the only thing a big
company can actually do to get
themselves ready for the real war of
Technology is marketing because it's
because it's you're spending it now it's
not like you have to go buy a FinTech
and overpay right because everything is
overpriced right the plan and I and and
then think about why I think this is so
practical I also think in parallel I
think most big companies are wasting 90
cents on the dollar and their current
marketing so to me it's like triple a
good idea to completely transform your
marketing capabilities team
infrastructure partners internal
external yet if you look at the early
examples they're very practical I'm a
businessman I'm not a futurist or you
know or a pun dn't this is all
practitioner ship this is all practical
this is about driving business results
I'm a true believer of empathy you talk
about thank you and it's very real and
you know what an empathy is what we're
talking about all this calms be
empathetic to where people's attention
is and again look you are the target and
you're telling me you're a great fan on
Instagram they're on there you are
watching me on Instagram yet as an
executive you're trying to debate is the
person you're reaching on there I see
this every day
you know because what happens is as a
human you're a human but as soon as you
come into the office you transform your
mindset happens all the time
sorry gay Pope photo yes yeah no problem
yes this is great I don't talk too many
different things I believe in I believe
in what I believe in
you know I think the crazy part is
people don't do people don't do you know
they're in hi I'm from the Star
newspaper such a pleasure sandy how are
you good monk over here she said what's
the one thing that businesses and
universities colleges can do for young
people no to prepare them for the future
what's to come by recognizing that
they're fundamentally broken and what
they're educating them on right now okay
and I and I think that takes humility
and empathy you know I have a lot of
respect for education systems and
companies but they have to recognize
that the curriculum that we are pushing
down our employees and students throats
nine out of ten times is outdated at
best and completely in outer space for
the reality the marketplace at worse you
know I think we're not preparing people
for success because a lot of times it's
not in our vested interest but how do
you do that I mean you hear so much talk
about you know chase your passion faint
your success
that journey but what is it specifically
but that's an ideology is to me I'm
talking about practicality you know in a
practicality standpoint if you're
teaching students think for example if
you're teaching in any manner that is
predicated on memorization that is
laughable yeah let's start there
every single piece of education in the
world that sits with memorization should
be eliminated because information is a
commodity it sits on your phone yeah hey
Siri who's the 19th president of United
States to me the fact that I know that
Rutherford B Hayes is the 19th president
United States that quickly makes me
laugh at every school in America that's
making kids memorize the presidents of
the United States it's lazy and so I
think we do a lot of that and so what
would I say in the same way that people
companies manage people and you know
don't let them post on social media like
it's yes and then it extends to the
furthest thing all these parents that
aren't letting their kids spend a lot of
time on the screen what world do you
think your kids gonna live in your kids
gonna live in a [ __ ] computer yeah
let it like it's gonna be like this
screens gonna be in them and your and
you're worried about their screen time
for what so they can read a book like
literally the device that's delivering
the information is your passion all
those parents that don't let their kids
play video games meanwhile their kids
could have become the most success
successful eSports players we fear
monger the future and we over respect
the past we fear the future and we over
respect over respect the past the past
is the past
nobody's going in a time machine so you
know I would say education and
businesses have a very common thing they
over respect the past
well I mean you got plenty of content
there Rd Rock Oh blog whatsapp vlog I
don't talk to you that much I appreciate
you guys I really really appreciate you
guys especially I've been reading a lot
of the comments lately super interesting
on nuances you guys pick up appreciate
it what I love about the blog more than
anything is just a complete body of work
right the consistency and just a grind
it is what it is pounding those same
themes it's so interesting to see how
many of you do two core things that
interest me one you hear the same thing
the 97 time in a different way and it
was the moment cuz you were ready for it
and number two really been enjoying the
people that I've been flying back in
after doing 80 days or a hundred days of
being summer off or watching something
else or hustling on something and coming
back and just seeing the value and the
consistency that's been the super
humbling when you guys make that
reference so I appreciate it you know
that there's a lot of people in this
room who have a passion but the reason
they don't leave their job right now is
not because they can't afford it but
because they don't want to take a step
back to date take three steps forward
there are people in this room who will
live the next 45 years on the light
unhappy because they've wanted two extra
bedrooms in their house that they will
never use um be that serious you so care
what other people think of you
you're not willing to sell your home and
go live in a neighborhood that's not as
nice drive a car that's not as nice to
start a business that will make you
happy and so you will stay in a job for
another 21 years that you hate just to
pay for the facade of success of
people's opinions that you value more
than your own happiness that [ __ ]
me like you would not believe it blows
my mind that most of the world is
willing to live their life completely
predicated on the judgment of other
people the reason you're not winning and
doing what you want is somebody's
opinion of you matters more than your
opinion of yourself somebody's opinion
of you matters you work to you than your
opinion of yourself it's very true and
I'm so desperate to figure out how you
know he's you know okay cool I'm up here
I'm on stage we're inspired for a second
you're pumped you're like yeah [ __ ] it
I'm gonna call my dad and tell him [ __ ]
you you know the problem is usually
between right this moment
and when you get home to make that call
it wears off right and so people ask me
you know why do I keep talking why do I
keep putting up logs why do I keep doing
my podcast why do you keep saying this
heals some people yell at me Gary you
keep saying the same things yes I
believe in them like one of my system
and make up something I don't believe in
to talk about yes I believe in it
because I know that for some of you
you've watched three years of my video
content and maybe this talk because
we're in the same room is the one maybe
it's not maybe you don't even know who I
am and this is the first time and then
you go watch a puppet start listening to
my podcast and 19 months from now I'll
say the same [ __ ] I just said here but
maybe because of the night before and
the weather and because it was audio
instead of video it clicks because
that's how this works
you've one life and the most scary thing
for me in the world is the look of
regret on somebody who's over 80 years
old the scariest thing in the world
to me in my bones that I feel is when I
meet somebody
over 80 years old and they have regret
on their face because time is really
close to running out and there's not a
lot more they can do when I look at this
audience the far majority under 60
you've got a fuckload more time and
here's the most interesting part and
this is just the most fascinating thing
about life everything that happened
yesterday back everything that happened
yesterday that means nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll go somewhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the problem is living living your life
based on somebody else's kpi's is
devastating
it's devastating it's it will never work
out in the end I'd rather parents and
kids fight for the first three years
then fight for the last three years once
you acknowledge it just don't lie to
yourself like once you stop lying to
yourself like it's Oh like once you
start you know blaming yourself owning
it yourself being yourself about it then
it is what it is then you can get into
step it changes everything it takes to
leverage away from anybody else and
leverage is what people need to focus on
because when you're doing something
because you don't have the leverage
that's devastating like that was kind of
the most interesting part of this talk
which was like all right here's what you
came for
it's two minutes now let's get to like
what you need that's what you think you
need let me tell you what you need
how are you to post on social media when
you're insecure listening to posts eight
times a day when you're when you don't
know how to take feedback I can tell you
everything to do on LinkedIn but if
you're scared to write that article
because you're scared to get fired from
your job just try it you know going
through my own process of trying to
figure out how the [ __ ] to help not
super complicated you know thank you for
coming man
thanks for being here yeah how are you
nice to meet you hey brother you would
teach my life when you really want to
personally thank you for that thank you
so much you pick one two three no you
pick one I'll have you know this is the
right one you don't you don't and let me
tell you a very very important thing I
believe one of the most fascinating
excuses in life is that I'm so good at
so many things that I don't know which
one to pick
I think it's an excuse and I think it's
ego and I think it's a vulnerability I
think it's [ __ ] I really do
pick one if you're so good at so many
things you'll pick one you'll be good at
that and you can do a bunch of things
I'm doing a bunch of things I don't want
to waste time because I'm so good at so
many things is an excuse to not do and
it's the worst one because you're trying
to act cool while not doing anything
I mean a man pick something if I can do
it your [ __ ] young kid you can do all
19 things welcome where's my sister
we should title it when you're good at
too many things I think we should slow
play them in there's a lot of people
think that's tender like that's me
millions will be destroyed on Instagram
I'm really glad I ran into you
thank you listen for that thanks oh it's
real just pick one right that was the
biggest that's not and then all we can
do that is it man undercover just do
something
no I mean do something about that excuse
I just an intimate caring about other
people
because you're positioning it as um you
know what I mean just do something and
don't give a [ __ ] if you fail they all
fail - thank you my friend
thank you guys that was crazy right
good evening one could say I was tough
on that kid when I he said you know that
he's good at so many things like you
know most people said that was the
biggest thing he took from the day he's
like that helped me more than anything
the weekend because here's why in it
it's by the way I don't like it
I hate negativity I don't want to give
him that advice but it's the truth and I
know the truth is always the best the
truth is when you say I'm too good at
too many things and I don't know which
one to pick not to waste my time it
means you're not how long have you been
watching my stuff I've been what two
years minimum what I - Gary Leon me and
Gary we as how many Canadian what comes
with Holly and Ian laughs and what was
the biggest thing that you learned in
this time that you did not pick up in
those two years however war
what seeing here injunctive and I
thought it so far as though we'll see
the system of you see Gary the most I
learned is giving value content because
all this work I think I'm giving I think
I'm not giving you notice you cuz
there's cuz they're still a little that
you're holding back for whatever reason
yes and I guess like I know that is that
is a real asset attention equals to s
mmm-hmm and currency currency so it's an
eyesore
hey it's Celina woodland stood up and
she says what I suppose I really don't
really get the content yet I guess it's
early but after the dinner I really get
it yeah I get it is so much
what you tomorrow all right so 7:45 down
here
yeah thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
[Applause]
such a pleasure I'm action or and I've
done a lot of the things that are being
talked about here two core things like
being the operator or being the
facilitator of the operation I've done a
lot of investing I've done a lot of
business running I've done a lot of
content creation and and the craziest
part is I think there's something
that'll probably be valuable for like
the whole crew like it's so crazy how
much life has been lived in this room
only surpassed by how much life we all
have left and I think it's I'm really
like fascinated by perspective I'm
starting to realized a lot more than I
even realized I think the most
interesting perspective is calibrating
time because it is a [ __ ] thing for
all of us like I really wish like as a
matter fact I just thought of something
for the first time in my life I don't
I never until this moment wanted to know
the day that I died right like I think
if we went around right now and did the
game of like do you want to know the day
you die like it like if you could know
most people and even I up until like 40
seconds ago would say no it's an
interesting thought and I would tell you
literally literally up until like a
minute ago and when I started talking I
never wanted to and I'm wondering if now
I would take it only because I think
time is like a really funny one I don't
know perspective is super on my mind
these days and I just wish I think
everybody's impatient like staggeringly
it is the shortcoming of most people and
I wish people would be more patient
because if you would you'd be so much
happier so not enough conversation about
how [ __ ] up parenting is in Asia
I think I think the most interesting
thing to me is what I struggle with with
parenting is accelerated in Asia like
it's unbelievable how it's unbelievable
how much parents do children as their
product and as a as a reflection of them
then in this global market global and
I'm being obviously generalizing but it
is unbelievably unhealthy it's
unbelievably unhealthy couldn't bring
you more I mean the best way to accept
yourself is to not hear anybody else
gets a lot easier like to me everybody
else sucks to like everybody else is bad
at something to like like I don't
understand dwelling on your weaknesses
in a world where others have other
nuances fake environments when you live
in a world that you can't afford because
you're keeping up with the Joneses
scary [ __ ] poison
a lot of people running the big credit
cards here to look right in their
environment hye-young
it's Gary B I'm here with your less
handsome brother happy happy [ __ ]
birthday I'm so proud of you man keep
doing your thing thank you so much for
watching the videos much love
thank you so much Mike yard it was
really cool I was expecting startups and
marketing but this is my foundation one
thing I didn't so it's like this
conversation about baked environments
it's an eye-opener because it works both
ways like I lost a job at some point and
I realized optimization the big created
the fake reality around losing his job
that I'd never thought of as a big
reality like to me I was like I'm bad
that was always a positive story in my
life and today I look back and I realize
anger I had in college for having to
work and put myself through that was
because of that big behind reverse and
if they haven't created a situation and
understood it matter I would've been too
docile I wouldn't have felt cheated
about seventeen hundred percent that was
beautiful because I've never seen under
percent a fake right cuz I always with
the rich kids I was like who have fake
reality I don't have one as I also but
now I'm like [ __ ] you know I had my fake
vo I haven't gotten to this part yet but
I know it exists some fake realities are
different and better and work like you
know like my hustle comes from that fake
reality but but I might have come in a
healthier way it might have come in a
healthy way that's it that's it that's
it duck today walking in here I still
feel like Oh
yeah it's admiration above its humility
of like I know what's happening with me
what like there's plenty people doing
better things different things time to
eat oh yes they could have come in a
healthy or could have coming out of your
way that's awesome yeah both of insights
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much we were leaving in Mexico you have
a great night so make sure you take care
looking forward to the Alexa telling you
about dinner was not upon me so much
[Applause]
nobody said shut
[Music]
thank you guys
didn't mean to be but thank you thank
you thank you have a good night nice
meeting all of you
[Music]